we're in Central America in Panama City
the biggest city in Panama and a mix of
old and new
Alexes express leader is on one of the
busiest streets in the center of town
600 people come for a snack year every
day the specialty here is butter CONUS
slices of fried plantain Rigoberto
Velazquez Cortez studied environmental
engineering but when he couldn't find a
job he turned to selling butter cornice
he's the boss of annexes expressed
leader and business is good weight
Panamanians love pasta khones I eat them
around the clock morning noon and night
Rick Alberto has been in the business
for 25 years now he and his staff
process 800 plantains a day
siempre compromise only by the best
plantains top quality is key if you want
to make the best pata corners
the fruit are peeled and cut into chunks
and then deep-fried
that indicate the name we won at the
Petula buzzer comforter call the
temperature has to be very high to make
a great Patek on you fried them for
quite a while the first time then they
get really crispy the second time after
the first round of frying the plantain
chunks are flattened and then they go
back into the hot oil outside they're
nice and crisp inside moist and soft
they're often eaten with meat or sausage
and a glass of teacher a sweet fruit
drink that's the best way to savor pata
Kony's if you have less than three four
or five dollars to spend on a lunch then
you'll eat uh tacones it's faster meat
and patagones because i prefer them to
rice we've been eating them since we
were kids
each buttock on costs the equivalent of
three Euro cents you buy as many as you
want environmental engineering is now a
thing of the past
Rigoberto will continue to make his
delicious pot okones for as long as he
can he has many fans and doesn't want to
disappoint